[Music]  some health news back here at home  center well senior primary care is a  brand new location in henderson off lake  mead parkway and water street  that makes eight total locations in  southern nevada celebrated its grand  opening today  doctors there say carewell facilities  are different than many urgent cares or  doctors offices when it comes to  clientele  we're totally senior focused which means  everything is about senior care we have  special flooring we have special seating  and we spend a lot more time with our  patients  doctors specially trained to meet the  needs of seniors aged 65 years and up  each center also features an activity  center offering health education  classes fitness demonstrations various  activities designed with seniors in mind